ce mercredi matin près de 150 lycéens
des Yvelines ont débattu à propos de
littérature dans le cadre du Forum
départemental du Prix littéraire des
lycéen apprenti et stagiaire de la
formation professionnelle
d'Île-de-France une nouvelle étape pour
la Maison des écrivains et de la
littérature de Paris à l'origine de
cette 2e édition en collaboration avec
la Maison de la poésie de Saint-Quentin
iveline on essaie de sensibiliser les
élèves à cette littérature adulte euh de
création littéraires récentes on essaie
de les faire rencontrer les auteurs de
les faire mettre en dialogue avec eux de
s'interroger d'être dans un argumentaire
aussi pour découvrir un livre une
écriture et aussi découvrir les métiers
et les espaces du livre la sélection
Eveline comporte trois romans un recueil
de poésie et une bande desessiné
graphique un projet qui court sur une
année scolaire et qui au début a rebuté
certains élèves au départ le projet leur
a fait un petit peu peur parce que lire
de la littérature
contemporaine un petit peu difficile ça
leur paraiss assz difficile et puis le
projet leur a fait peur aussi peut-être
parce qu'elles ont voulu reconduire des
des schémas de travail qu'elle faisait
au collège et quand on leur a expliqué
qu'il fallait qu'elle juge elles ont été
un petit peu dérouté finalement les
élèves se sont investis et ont même pris
goût à l'exercice trop de référen
historique une écriture qui casse les
codes sans ponctuation du sarcasme et un
côté fantastique plaisant voici
quelques-unes des remarques entendues au
début j'ai pris Congo parce que je suis
congolaise et je pensais qu'il parlerait
du Congo Congo sauf que comme il y a de
Congo et ben il parlait pas de mon Congo
donc bah j'ai pas accroché à cause de ça
et que en plus j'aime pas
tropin qui comme il parle de la
colonisation c'est bien mais moi ça me
ça m'intéresse pas donc j'ai pas aimé et
donc j'ai choisi Formose parce que
Formose il y a pas beaucoup d'écrit
d'écriture prochaine étape déterminé par
un système de vote individuel un lauréa
il sera dévoilé lors du salon du livre
de Paris qui se déroulera du 22 au 25
mars Porte de
Versailles